as gotham's dark knight batman
has saved the city from peril on
countless occasions
but bruce wayne is only human after all
and even he makes mistakes
these are the gotham villains that
batman himself had a hand in creating
much of what makes the joker so
terrifying is the mystery surrounding
his true origins
i wanna know how i got these scars
while most major dc comics characters
have clear
and concise origin stories the joker's
various creation myths are openly
acknowledged as being mostly made up by
the man himself
it's assumed by most fans that they'll
never know the truth about the joker's
beginnings for certain
but some stories do hang on with unique
tenacity
joker's most popular comics origin story
comes from 1987's the killing joke
in which joker recounts his origins as a
down on his luck stand-up comedian
who suffers a string of tragedies that
gradually send him mad
of course he pretty much immediately
recants this tale
too but there's no doubt that it's the
one origin that is endured in the minds
of fans
in this version of the joker's origins
he crosses paths
with batman one fateful night at ace
chemicals
the man who would be joker is there as
part of a heist
in the guise of the red hood a tuxedo
and helmet-clad gangster
there he is confronted by batman then
still a novice crime fighter
but more than a match for the red hood
their struggle ends with the red hood
leaping over a catwalk railing into a
vat of chemicals in order to escape
he's washed into the river and emerges
with bleached skin
green hair and a permanent sickly grin
this story is taken as gospel then
batman
is forced to forever wonder how many
lives might have been saved
if the fighted ace chemicals had gone
differently
if you're asking about villains made by
batman then matches malone is as literal
as it gets
because batman is matches malone in fact
matches malone is a persona utilized by
batman whenever he needs to infiltrate
the crime underworld
a pinstripe clad gangster from hoboken
malone is a pyromaniac
a teetotaler and if you believe the
rumors a squealer to the batman
since he'll often take a job as muscle
and then fail to show up before the dark
knight drops in
matches malone is not a wholesale
invention though
he's based off an arsonist who batman
encounters early in his career
and presumes to have died he takes on
malone's identity for his own purposes
for years
and after a certain point most of
gotham's criminals have never even met
the real malone
over the years batman builds his version
of malone into a respected figure in
gotham's underworld
and even devises a contingency plan to
maneuver malone into position
to take direct control of gotham's gangs
in the 2004 story arc batman war games
stephanie brown aka spoiler steals this
plan
in an attempt to bring down gotham's
underworld and demonstrate her value as
a partner to batman
unfortunately she does this without
knowing malone's true identity
and without alerting batman himself when
malone fails to appear at a critical
moment
a gang war breaks out that nearly tears
gotham apart
as it turns out the most dangerous thing
matches malone could do
is not show up at all in 1992's batman's
sword of azrael
batman encounters john paul valley aka
azrael a genetically enhanced
hypnotically conditioned knight of the
ancient order of saint dumas
batman and azrael soon find themselves
on the same side
and asriel is invited to train alongside
robin as part of batman's ever expanding
family of crime fighters
mere months later in the much celebrated
nightfall story arc
batman loses a battle with the
muscle-bound mastermind bane
and is left a paraplegic thus bruce
wayne passes the mantle of the bat to
jean paul
the apprentice he's worked with for the
shortest length of time
and knows the least about no one but
bruce thinks this is a very good idea
bruce then jets off across the pond for
a year to seek a remedy for his broken
back
leaving the new batman or asbats with
the run of the cave
but as bats finds himself haunted by his
subconscious programming
and constrained by the rules and
conventions of being batman
and he gradually adopts more and more
violent methods of crime fighting
eventually he becomes little more than
an executioner in an armored suit
transformed from hero to villain a
freshly recovered bruce wayne is
ultimately forced to take down the mad
pretender
and restore the dignity of batman
batman is a brilliant detective and an
olympic level athlete
but his most important asset might still
be his mountain of wealth
it's only fitting then that there's one
villain who in the words of dick grayson
is made possible by a grant from the
wayne foundation
introduced in a 1994 episode of batman
the animated series
lyle bolton is a top shelf security
expert who is hired at arkham asylum on
bruce's recommendation
on paper bolden is a great choice for
putting a stop to the asylum's infamous
weekly jailbreaks
but once he's in place he proves to be
an extravagantly
cruel jailer delighting in the abusive
inmates like scarecrow
and harley quinn he says scum like us
must be kept in line
that's why he chains us down at night
and electrifies our doors
appalled bruce sees to bolton's swift
dismissal
bolton vows revenge not only on the
inmates who reported his abuse
but on the establishment that he
believes to be coddling criminals
he invents the costume persona of lockup
kidnaps a number of prominent people
and holds them captive in an offshore
battleship turned prison
lockup is defeated by batman and robin
before he can do any more damage
and returns to arkham as an inmate where
he relishes the chance to keep a close
eye on his former prisoners
there's no antagonist for whom batman
can take more personal responsibility
than jason todd
aka the red hood after parting ways with
dick grayson
batman decides to hand the mantle of
robin to a juvenile delinquent named
jason todd
batman first encounters todd when he
discovers the kid has
boosted the tires off the batmobile
which is just about the gutsiest thing
one could do on the streets of gotham
concerned for his future but impressed
by his moxie batman offers jason a new
home
and a new purpose as robin the boy
wonder
jason never quite sheds the chip on his
shoulder however
and has difficulty playing by batman's
rules
frustrated and confused jason is lured
into a trap by the joker
who beats him within an inch of his life
with a crowbar and leaves him to die in
a warehouse explosion in 1988's batman
a death in the family batman carries his
guilt over
jason's apparent death for years even as
he attempts to move on with his life
jason eventually resurfaces fashioning
himself after the joker's original
masked identity in order to enact
his revenge against his would-be killer
as the new red hood
jason terrorizes batman to punish him
for leaving joker alive
in the years since his return red hood
has oscillated between villain and
anti-hero
but wherever he lands he never stays
there for long
batman has always had trust issues but
during one particularly dark chapter in
his career
his paranoia grows so rampant that he
resorts to extremes usually reserved for
government intelligence agencies
after he discovers that members of the
justice league have conspired to tamper
with his memory
batman develops a global network of
orbital surveillance satellites
governed by an artificial intelligence
called brother i
brother i covertly monitors meta-humans
including batman's allies and is meant
to prevent future violations of his
trust
predictably this backfires as brother i
is hijacked by checkmate double agent
maxwell lord
to surveil superheroes and assimilate
unsuspecting civilians into armored
super soldiers
brother i is later granted sentience by
an alternate universe as alexander
luthor
and is used in a complex plan to bring
about a new multiverse
becoming brother i this time spelled
e-y-e
in a twist of irony batman must enlist a
small army of super-powered allies to
destroy the satellite
batman has made his share of mistakes
but usually he at least has good
intentions
building a skynet scale cybernetic
intelligence to spy on his friends
though
this may be the dark knight's all-time
biggest blunder
the story is familiar a mother a father
and a young boy walk innocently into a
dark alley
and are confronted by a man with a gun
but this time around batman arrives to
save the family
this is what batman was made to do
he prevents the exact kind of heartbreak
that created him
batman's luck being what it is though
means
even this story ends in tragedy the boy
in this story
hank clover grows up idolizing batman
and takes his example to heart
he and his sister claire trained their
minds and bodies for years
in the hopes of following in batman's
footsteps
sadly the malevolent genius bane
exploits their good intentions
offering them a procedure that will give
them the powers of superman
naturally it comes with a catch the more
they use their powers
the sooner they'll die believing that a
short life doing enormous good is
worthwhile
hank and claire undergo the procedure
and become gotham
and gotham girl the siblings get to live
their dream of working alongside batman
to protect gotham city
but the dream is predictably short-lived
as part of his master plan bane
unleashes the emotion manipulating
psycho-pirate turning them both mad
gotham goes on a killing spree
and is only defeated by the combined
might of gotham girl
and the justice league they force hank
to use up his powers and he dies in his
sister's arms
there are those who argue that batman
does more bad than good in gotham city
that his very presence provokes the
violence around him
the victim syndicate are a quintet of
villains who embody this argument
each count themselves as collateral
damage in batman's war on crime
and make it their mission to shut down
his operation for good
mr noxious is a recovered thrall of
poison ivy's
whose experiments made him a toxic
presence to those around him
literally madame crow is a psychiatrist
and a survivor of scarecrow's torturous
early fear toxin experiments
and now employs similar chemical weapons
of her own
the mute lost his larynx after exposure
to joker's laughing gas
and has since acquired the ability to
block sound waves
mudface is a former friend of clayface
who was
left with melting flesh after being
drowned in the chemicals that first made
the villain into a shape-shifting
monster
their leader the first victim remains
anonymous
but claims to be the very first innocent
to suffer from batman's actions
together they face off against batman
and his team of allies
attempting to shake their resolve and
turn public opinion against them
the victim syndicate fails to defeat or
unmask batman
but they do win one small victory they
receive a sincere apology from the dark
knight himself
so here's a question is batman good for
bruce wayne
bruce wayne had his parents taken from
him as a child
and with them is hope thus bruce
embraces
fear as an ally forging it into a
powerful symbol against those who would
take hope from others
but in so doing bruce wayne sacrifices
his body
and his emotional well-being again and
again even when he's offered a way out
i'm afraid that if i go back out there
i'll fail
[Music]
i'm afraid that you want to
even as he builds a support system
around himself
bruce wayne cannot stop being batman
and being batman smothers every other
part of his life
there are times of relative peace for
bruce when being batman is more
fulfilling than it is punishing
he has even been able to free himself
from the pain of his parents loss for a
time
but it never lasts bruce wayne is a
human being
batman however is unrelenting they need
each other
but of the two of them only one is
immortal
and whatever it eventually reads on
bruce wayne's death certificate
we'll know the truth it'll be batman who
really killed him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about dc comics
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you